i am in love okay i feel like there is a  man i think he likes himself a lot i do  i don't think he's afraid of like  poofing his chest out or almost like a  football player i feel like there may be  a little distance maybe you want to live  with him but there's there still feels  to be some physical distance are you  technically engaged yet or no not yet  okay but you know this is the one right  okay he knows you're the one too i  believe i believe i just ruined  uh an engagement don't tell them i don't  think you're ruining this i mean you're  totally right spot right on everything  i'm in a long-distance relationship yeah  for the past three years he is a former  college football player oh fun  so you were on the night that's great  thank you  i'm getting married that's right